California congressman Adam Schiff is
the ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee good morning
congressman good morning before we get
to James Comey this attack on Syria how
do we know the intelligence was right
well I had a chance to speak to the
director about attribution of Syria and
what kind of attack it was and I'm
confident that we know it was a chemical
weapons attack and that the regime
carried it out so I'm fully confident in
that I look I think the president did a
couple things right and one big thing
wrong I think he was right to have
strikes on these chemical facilities as
a deterrent of Bashar al-assad to try to
reestablish this norm against the use of
chemical weapons and I think he was
right to pick targets that would not
risk Russian lives and embroil us in a
broader war using sanctions against the
Russians which they're apparently going
to employ I think is the right approach
rather than bombing Russian targets but
on the negative side of the ledger this
should've been brought to Congress for a
vote it morally justified but probably
unconstitutional let me ask you about
James Comey you said after his decision
to reinitiate the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's email this was a very
serious error in judgment the
Republicans are using that now so if he
is capable of that kind of a serious
error in judgment why should people
listen to him now well I've always found
him to be very credible very honest I
think he's explaining why he made the
decisions that he did as flawed in my
judgment as they were but I've never had
a reason to question his either his
intelligence or his honesty I think he's
giving us what he thought at the time
why he did what he did
I think his recollections of his
conversations with the president which
he memorialized are spot on and and and
unfortunately resonate all too much
particularly when he concludes that this
is a president who's morally unfit for
the office your committee is
investigating Russian interference I use
you know you're familiar with what Comey
has said in the past what did you learn
new from his interview well you know
honestly I didn't learn all that much
new probably what struck me the most was
his description of the president and
those around him like a mob family that
was a new insight and and frankly it
resonates with what we
scene of the president I think it makes
a lot of sense and the fact that so many
around him are willing to propagate his
falsehoods that is mob kind of behavior
anything in the service of the boss so
that struck me but in terms of the
actual facts I've had a chance to read
his memos here is testimony in Iraq with
him I obviously was there as part of the
gang of eight when we were first
learning about what the Russians were
doing and his interviews seemed complete
consistency uh me said and continues to
say that one of his number-one goals was
to appear unbiased he says he did not
vote for that reason he didn't like
being alone with presidents for that
reason given that what do you make of
some of the criticism that he's
receiving now by talking about things
like the size of the president's hands
and whether his hair is real and whether
he goes to a tanning bed some say that
plays into the president's argument that
he is in fact biased I look I think
those kind of observations add color to
the book I don't particularly put a lot
of weight in them I think the the real
gravamen of what he's writing about and
what he's talking about is the danger
that the country is in when we can't
trust our president to do the right
thing or even to say what is factually
true
that's a terrible indictment of any
president the fact that he can't say and
we can't say that the Russians of
foreign nation adversary doesn't have
something over the president in itíd
States this ought to concern all
Americans it's why you know I'm so
determined to make sure that Muller can
do his work that the president's stay
out of his way because the Congress and
the country need to get answers and make
sure that the president is acting in our
interest not in his own personal
interests I think the former FBI
director did is that he hinted at the
word at the possibility that the
Russians have something that could
blackmail President Trump but he offered
no evidence based on everything you've
seen what is your take well I think I'm
very much in a position of James Comey
which is the investigation still has
more work to do one of the issues that
concerns me the most Congress is not
investigating and I don't know if Bob
was investigating that is worth of
Russians laundering money through the
Trump Organization
there are a number of credible
allegations along these lines that to me
would be far more compromising than any
salacious video after stormy Daniels how
compromising could of salacious video be
how laundering it by Russians who needed
to unload lots of money a Trump
organization that's in in trouble
financially can't borrow money from
banks the only bank that seems to lend
them money and massive amounts is
Deutsche Bank which had to pay hundreds
of millions in fines for laundering
Russian money so this may be a red line
of the president's for a reason but he
is not entitled to draw red lines but it
looks like Muller is looking into all of
that you said he's not we don't know you
know the New York Times piece recently
said that he contemplated firing Muller
until he was assured that Muller was not
subpoenaed Deutsche Bank I would hope
that Muller is subpoenaing Deutsche Bank
we should be doing that in Congress we
should find out and be able to tell the
American people there's no truth to
these allegations or there's all too
much truth to these allegations
congressman Schiff thank you for joining
us here we appreciate it
thank you